uh our next speaker is lin yang lin yang
is an assistant professor at ucla
and he's a facebook novi research fellow
in the reinforcement learning program
okay thanks for saying and thanks very
much to give me their fellowship
so here am i talking about reinforcing
learning again so every single year so
we all know that
he personally has achieved the
phenomenon in people's successes
because it can be used to solve but
let's say go games
against the best human player or use
that to control let's see simple games
like natari or control robots
like okay ir the next slide please
yeah so in practice people like usually
and
receives like a huge steak space in
order to solve this problem when people
use
neural networks to do function
approximation so here i'm
talking about particular methods in
person learning that's called q learning
so basically if you produce neural
network to um
represent a particular function called q
function that measures how good their
particle actually is for reinforcement
learning
okay so this actually this method that
has
has been responsible for the huge
increase of success next step is
uh for instance at this statement paper
these they are using different poisoning
basically using a different network to
represent the queue function
and then in many control types tasks
because
this method has been achieving um
superhuman performance however this is a
simple method
and has some problems the first problem
is that it really requires a huge number
of samples for instance with this simple
atari game
so the human beings human being can
master the game in matters of minutes
however these algorithms requires like
the equivalent to the hundreds of hours
of human experience in order to
play good so on other kind of because
it's using some very uh
complex functions like uh multi-layer
neural networks
hardly have any like theoretical
guarantees no hybrid
like we can't have any understanding of
them so and this kind of algorithm can
hardly be applied to other scenarios
like risky
sensitive uh scenarios okay
so an expertise so we really wanted to
understand
like the uh why and how and when
personal learning works within course
the risk function approximation
so in order to do so we uh first
consider very simple function
approximation forms that's the linear
function approximation forms
so in this setting we really like the
hybrid profile have been provided
features for instance for each state
which is the framework pictures what we
use
we can map that to it to be a simple
vectors and then we can claim that
we can assume that the value function
the optimal control the value function
can be represented approximately well
we're a linear function approximately
using these features
okay but the thing is that good thing
okay next step is
this thing uh usually provides very good
guarantees for other types of uh
machine learning for instance in
manchester uni
as soon as you have this combination you
can learn to get a correct
representation
with a very small number of samples
however in reinforcement learning it's
not the case
in our recent paper we show that this
if you have the exact same structure
it's going to require
exponential samples which explains in
part
the practical observations next at least
so in order to handle this we really
need to design very good features with
good guarantees basically we're
considering here
is a structure that the this environment
type where
structure that's a factorization okay
the next methods
so is this kind of a representation with
this kind of a structure we can use that
very easy algorithm that's basically d
squared
so feed the q value and you can have a
very good algorithm that
you if that can work for uh neonatal
books as well
this next one so with this algorithm as
you can see here's
this picture of this algorithm in
practice it really works well
and uh more importantly in special cases
as long as the function has a complexity
in terms of included dimension we can
show that this algorithm
prove solve the problem with a small
number of samples
so that's the result thanks